El siguiente diagrama de cinta describe la
cantidad de pintura de roja y pintura azul
en la pintura de color "Púrpura ciruela".
Así que éste sería el total de pintura
"Púrpura ciruela" y me dice que está conformado
por cuatro partes de pintura roja y tres partes
de pintura azul.
¿La relación entre la cantidad de pintura
roja y la pintura azul,
es proporcional la pintura color "Púrpura ciruela"?
Esa es la primera pregunta y pues antes que
nada noten que en el diagrama puedo inferir
que si tengo una lata o una cantidad de pintura
"Púrpura ciruela",
entonces está conformada por cuatro
parte rojo y tres partes azul.
Dicho de otro modo, la razón de pintura roja
a pintura azul es de 4 a 3
ó dicho de aún otro modo, la razón de pintura azul ahora
a pintura roja es de 3 a 4.
Bien, entonces, supongamos que tengo cuatro
latas de pintura roja, como en este caso,
¿entonces, cuántas latas de pintura azul necesité
para hacer pintura de color "Púrpura ciruela"?
Pues yo sé que con 4 latas de rojo, necesito
tres latas de azul,
por lo tanto aquí la respuesta sería 3.
Ahora, si tengo 6 latas de pintura azul,
¿cuántas latas de pintura roja necesito
para hacer pintura de color "Púrpura ciruela"?
Pues 6 es el doble que 3 y si para hacer la
pintura requerí 3 latas de pintura azul
y 4 latas de pintura roja, para hacer el doble
voy a necesitar el doble de rojo,
así que necesitaría 8 latas de pintura roja.
Grafica los puntos correspondientes a la tabla.
Ok, vamos a bajar un poco y nos dan esta gráfica
así que puedo arrastrar esto y bueno,
yo sé que el eje "x", es el eje de la pintura
roja y el eje "y"es el eje de la pintura azul.
Así que para 4 latas de pintura roja, requiero
3 latas de pintura azul,
para hacer 7 latas de pintura "Púrpura ciruela".
Y para hacer... para hacer 14 latas de pintura
"Púrpura ciruela",
si tengo 8 latas de pintura roja,
necesito 6 latas de pintura azul.
Así que ahí está.
Ahora sí, contestemos la pregunta,
¿es la relación proporcional?
Pues vamos a ver, en esta gráfica tengo que
esto es una gráfica lineal,
es una línea recta que además pasa por el origen.
Y justo estoy diciendo que la relación sí
es proporcional, cuando me dieron el diagrama
de cinta, dije que la proporción siempre
era de 4 latas de roja por cada 3 latas de azul,
así que esa relación sí es proporcional.
Otra pista de que es proporcional es que esta
gráfica pasa por el 0, pero bueno no tengo...
si aquí, si tengo 4 latas de roja, requiero
3 de azul, si tengo 8 latas de roja,
requiero 6 de azul.
Y si tuviera por ejemplo, 12 latas de roja,
entonces requeriría tres veces esta cantidad,
o sea, 9 latas de azul.
Así que la relación sí es proporcional.
Sí, la relación es proporcional.
Chequemos y muy bien.
Déjenme explico con un poco
más de detalle ese último punto.
Bien, pues yo dije que en la pintura "Púrpura
ciruela", la proporción de la pintura azul
a la pintura roja... a la pintura roja...
siempre era la misma, eso es lo que me decía
el diagrama de cinta y esa proporción era
3 partes de azul por cada cuatro partes de rojo.
Y de hecho, de aquí podría despejar, multiplicando
por la cantidad de pintura roja y obtener
que la cantidad de latas o la cantidad e pintura azul,
siempre va a ser 3 cuartas partes de la cantidad de pintura roja empleada.
Por lo tanto si es una relación proporcional,
la cantidad de pintura azul es una constante por la cantidad de pintura roja.
Y noten que si no quisiera usar nada de pintura,
si uso 0 latas de pintura roja entonces usaría
0 latas de pintura azul.
Por lo tanto, todas las relaciones proporcionales
pasan por el origen,
pasan por el 0 y son una línea recta,
son funciones lineales.